when you came full circle and like the
pandemic started and you have two young
children yes
what was that like
yeah it was a it was a rough time and it
was why i wrote the book we were sitting
around you know with the pandemic and
the george floyd
had been murdered and there was
anti-asian violence erupting
and the kids were underfoot and we were
just sort of searching for a way to
explain it all to them
and as a result i started thinking about
another incident of police brutality
when i was younger
the rodney king eating and so i started
thinking about
the immigrant journey also like what is
this country that
uh that that i thought i was coming to
and what is it now and all this and it
so um the book
is about a boy who
uh a bit of a troublemaker who comes
home he's suspended
and uh his parents own a liquor store in
south central l.a
um and it's april 29 1992 the day the
verdict is being read the father goes to
the store to board it up
and
the boy seeing the news reports grows
increasingly desperate and decides
that the best way to protect his father
is to take his dad's gun from the closet
and deliver it to him for protection
that night
so it's a poor decision but an
interesting story as the boy tries to
get across los angeles and is it true
that your sons read it
yes and like contributed to like
compliments like or
you know i or did you run it by them
yeah here's my authenticity reader at
the end i was like is this uh
how'd i do how'd i do and he said um
good job daddy uh
what did your parents like think i mean
you you know you moved here from korea
at a young age did they instill like
their honest life to you and life
lessons about your future what did they
think when you told them you wanted to
be an actor
when i told them i wanted to be an actor
i think they were just really worried
that i was going to
be found dead in an apartment from
starvation you know they were just
worried that
i wouldn't be able to pay the bills my
dad did say
you want to become an actor and i
and this is the 90s so he i think all he
saw was connie chung on television he
said uh maybe you want to read the news
is that is that somewhere you want to go
and i said that's not what i want to do
but i can see the logic there were
that was an asian lady um
and i think he just didn't feel that
there were any opportunities for asians
on television did you ever get their
stamp of approval
i did because um when
when i was in the there was a
small feature in the local korean
newspaper that's when i had made it
in there in their eyes see isn't that
beautiful yeah
well speaking of actors and films and
movies we were just chatting all things
oscars do you have any favorites this
year
the one i that stood out to me and i
still have to do my viewing is king
richard
and i think will smith has never been
better
i just have to say as one human to
another i really am like one of your
biggest fans oh my goodness
i love you
get your copy of troublemaker it's in
stores now
[Music]
you